the documentary you're about to watch is
a nebula original
that means it was funded by and released
on the streaming platform nebula
first we thought though that this one in
particular would be important to get out
to the widest audience possible given
how important the subject matter is
it is though going to be one of the last
nebula originals uploaded to youtube as
we're phasing that out
i hope this serves as evidence for you
on just how high quality the content on
nebula is
and each week new originals come out
from some of the top educational content
creators
if you want to see more nebula is
available through a bundle deal with
curiositystream for just
15 a year at their current sale pricing
and that's available only by going to
curiositystream.com
wendover now to the marshall islands
they listened in the muscle size that
the
martial islands were created by a cat
his name was
lower it descended on the
athol of islam and he created the
islands by
saying aroma and islands and there were
islands
alone people and there were people all
iron fish
and there was fish and on and on like
that
our lands you know like our mothers you
know they provide all everything in our
ocean same thing
yeah we've always thought about the
ocean at our friends
but now it's becoming a threat to us
you know when you find a globe and you
give it a whirl
and it goes around and around and around
and then as the going slows
your eyes come to a rest on a dash of
color that has never caught your
attention before
a spot that sits on the part of the
sphere you normally spin
right past an island so isolated that
you're not
even sure how you'd explain where it is
somewhere whose story is seen
as insignificant a land that's lost to
most of the world
left out of the history books apart from
a passing
mention that place is here
the republic of the marshall islands but
unknown untold unremembered places
aren't unique
what makes the marsh island story
singular is not that it's unrecognized
from above
but because it's under siege from below
and is only when you see it from the
middle that you can understand
why go on take a look you won't have the
chance
for long we can talk more about the end
of their world later but first i've got
to tell you about what we've got here
it's a small nation the marshall islands
with a bit over 50 000 residents and 70
square miles of land split up into 29
atolls
thin rings of land encircling saltwater
lagoons while significant populations
can be found
on 13 of those atolls over half of the
marshallese people can be found
on this one magico about 28 000 people
live on the capital atoll and none of
those 28 000
live more than a few minutes walk from
the ocean the furthest you can get from
the water
is about 2 000 feet or 600 meters inland
but
that's an anomaly in most spots water
flanks you closely
on both sides in some spots the atoll
gets so thin
that you could stand in the lagoon and
have a conversation with someone
standing
in the ocean life on a remote sunny
coral atoll may sound idyllic
but the population density of maturo
greater than that of bahrain
bermuda or bangladesh has not been kind
to the mother atoll in a part of the
world usually thought of as pristine
sparse and pastoral majoro is instead
gritty
overcrowded and urbanized it's far
from an island paradise based on the
2011 census which is the last census we
had
average household size on madrid was
about seven people
and household income is probably about
sixteen thousand dollars
in that neighborhood um well i mean
sixteen thousand divided by seven
you know it can be that can be a
challenge that can be tough
here's the problem some places are poor
because they haven't yet seized their
opportunity
others are poor because they have no
majoro is in that second category
characteristics of the economy here in
the islands
is you know you're looking at fish
coconuts people
i mean outside of that our natural
resources are fairly scarce
and then combined with our challenges
with
education and skills attainment makes it
even more challenging
with people being you know our third
largest natural resource
those are some major inhibitors for you
know sustaining
economic growth expanding the economy
here in the islands
like many small island nations the
marshall islands doesn't have too much
in the way of natural resources worth
exporting
and even when it does manage to produce
something people might want to buy
the cost of shipping it to those
potential buyers will have pumped up the
price so much
that it's no longer worth it one of the
very few things they make decent
business
of selling abroad is cobra or dried
coconut meat which is produced mainly on
outer atolls and then brought into
masuro for processing
it's a work intensive process mostly
conducted by families who form informal
assembly lines getting paid 50 cents a
pound
and even that low wage is the result of
heavy government
subsidies because creating viable export
goods is so difficult
most of the jobs in the marshall islands
are either in government or the
subsistence economy
in other words most people in the
marshall islands are providing services
or making goods exclusively for the
marshall islands
which leaves very little opportunity for
growth but
the country does have one tiny little
asset that keeps it
running it's location a location that
makes the marshall island attractive to
one of the world's
biggest businesses the u.s military
the american military presence can be
found mainly on kwajalein atoll which
serves as a key test site for the u.s
ballistic missile defense system
among other purposes in the end it's
simple logic
the us military wants access to the
marshall islands the marshall islands
wants money and security
and thus an agreement exists the compact
a free association so the compact of
free association
is basically lays the foundation for the
relationship between the united states
and the freely associated states one
section of the compact deals with the
relationship between our
peoples and it allows for qualified
citizens to live and work and study in
the united states without a visa
there's another section of the compact
that generally governs
economics and it provides for grants and
services
all kinds of usg assistants coming to
the marshall islands
and the third big section of the compact
has to do with
security provisions the united states is
the guarantor of
security in the marshall islands it's
difficult to overstate the significance
of the compact it's the basis for the
entire modern
economic and political system of the
marshals and while each of the three
sections has an enormous impact on the
country
perhaps none is more consequential than
the second
financial aid the marshals are
heavily dependent on
[Music]
money from donors uh or from the united
states
that's a tremendous part of uh
national income upwards of 70 80
the us provides approximately 100
million dollars every year to the rmi as
a combination of grants and services and
programs
now it's a big world out there and there
are quite a few places the us could send
100 million dollars a year
in exchange for military access so why
here
why is there this strange partnership
between one of the world's largest
superpowers
and one of the world's smallest
countries well
like most strange things it came as a
result of millions of years
of chance and circumstance about 70
million years ago
29 ancient volcanoes in what we now call
the north pacific
came to life and spewed out lava which
quickly cooled and built up into
under volcanic structures until they
grew so much
that they emerged above water and became
islands
around these islands coral began to form
eventually coalescing into what's known
as a fringing coral reef
which encircled each island time went on
the dinosaurs ruled then died or became
birds and mammals started mattering and
so on and so on and as that all happened
those islands were slowly eroding and
undergoing subsidence
they slowly sunk into the sea eventually
the islands disappeared under the ocean
but the coral reefs that had formed
around them
remained it is these 29 rings of coral
called antles that make up what's now
known as the marshall islands
sometime millions of years later but
four thousand years before today
the first martial east settlers arrived
on the islands coming from either here
here here or here or some combination of
those places
they split the atolls into two chains
the eastern relic or sunrise chain and
the western rata
or sunset chain from those early
martials eight clans emerged of which
four became dominant
the chiti conquered northern relic the
arab rajoy took southern relic
and the rumayore clan conquered nearly
all of ratak but then gave nearly all of
it to their offspring of the random clan
these early martialees wore traditional
clothing which looked like this
lived in large community-based homes
which looked like this and practiced a
religion that involved complex dances
and tattoos which looked like this
the first western explorers to find the
marshall islands were spaniards
and there were a few of them the first
one was this guy in 1526 then this guy
in 1529 and then this guy
in 1530. over the next 300 years more
explorers stopped through the marshals
including frenchmen russians and this
guy british captain john charles
marshall in 1788
after whom the islands were named on
western maps
technically during this time the spanish
claimed sovereignty over the marshall
islands as part of the spanish east
indies which included all of this
but that claim was largely just
theoretical the spanish
never had a formal administration never
tried to exert influence
and never really even visited apart from
those early explorers whose only real
impact had been giving the martial ease
european diseases
much more relevant to the actual history
of the marshals was the presence of
these people
boston missionaries who first arrived in
1857 aboard the morning star
they landed here on ebenetol and were
met by chief kabua whose great
great some number of great-grandson was
the first president of the marshall
islands and who some
greater number of great's grandson is
the current president
chief kabua allowed the missionaries to
stay there where they began spreading
christianity throughout the islands
not only were they teaching them about
this guy in this book they also
actively changed marshally's culture
even going so far as to ban traditional
tattooing and dancing because they
referenced the traditional martiales
religion
soon the marshall islands changed even
more as the first genuine western
settlers the germans
began to make residents in the islands
in 1875 they signed a treaty of
friendship with chief kabua and
developed a consulate
trading posts and economic ties
eventually buying the marshals from
spain in 1885 the same year they worked
with chief kabua to make the marshall
islands an official german protectorate
also importantly they brought in more
missionaries who spread even more
christianity but then in 1914
the germans decided to invade here which
led to here invading here and then here
invading
here and then here invading here and
then here invading here and also not
that many people paid attention to it
the japanese invading here the marshall
islands
japan took the marshals in part for
strategic reasons
in part for economic reasons after all
even in the final years of german rule
they controlled over 80 percent of the
island's trade
once world war one ended and all these
people got together to sign the treaty
of versailles the council of the league
of nations gave control of the marshall
islands to the japanese
while in power they expanded their
administration introduced japanese
culture
and moved about 1 000 japanese citizens
to the islands
but then because of some things going on
here and here and also here
the japanese decided to drop bombs here
which led to the united states entering
world war ii
eventually taking the marshals from the
japanese in 1944
and then came this
when the united states dropped atomic
bombs on hiroshima and nagasaki
it began a new chapter in the world's
history
the nuclear age these atomic footprints
on the sands of time can never be erased
they point a path which leads to
unparalleled progress
or unparalleled destruction
just as in the darkness of the desert
morning when the atomic age was born
atomic power puts the questions squarely
to mankind
for some it was exciting there were
mushroom cloud cakes
misatomic beauty pageants and talk of
unlimited clean energy
unparalleled military dominance and an
everlasting world peace
but of course the enduring legacy of
nuclear weapons is not
peace or energy
destruction and while what happened in
hiroshima and nagasaki can be found in
any book of modern history
there's another chapter of the nuclear
story that's told far
less often that of the martial islands
so what happened at the end of world war
ii
was there had already been three nuclear
weapons detonated one in new mexico and
then hiroshima and nagasaki
but the united states at that time not
just the united states the russians too
they wanted to increase their knowledge
about the nuclear testing
and so they needed a testing ground and
when they looked around the globe they
needed
several requirements for a proving
ground for their nuclear testing
had to be out of the way of major
airline and shipping routes
had to be under the control of the
united states had to have a really
wide area lagoon to
anchor the ships to do the testing with
somewhere really far out of the way they
looked around the map and they
saw bikini bikini atoll sits at the
northern end of the rally chain
2.3 square miles of land encircling a
229 square mile lagoon
it was perfect the right size the right
shape the right location and the right
political status as the u.s had been
given jurisdiction over the marshall
islands at the end of the war
and so on to tiny bikini atoll the
united states moved in
42 000 personnel on 242 ships and began
to experiment with the greatest power
ever
unleashed by mankind first there was the
crossroads able bomb
21 kilotons far greater than little boy
the 15 kiloton bomb dropped on hiroshima
then
crossroads baker 23 kilotons but these
were nothing
compared to what came next castle bravo
detonated
on march 1 1954 this bomb produced the
most powerful explosion
the world had ever seen 15 megatons 1
000 times more powerful
than the hiroshima bomb for the united
states
it was a triumph the greatest example
yet of nuclear technology's potential
for nerje joseph a neighboring rongolab
atoll
it was the start of a long nightmare
my name is nerji joyet i come from
brahma
and i was born in rome i was in drama
in 1954 then nuclear
something nerje was only eight on bravo
day
today at 74 she still remembers it
vividly
the powder of course was nuclear fallout
pulverized pieces of coral laced with
radiation that had been shot
up into the air and carried by wind on
taronga lab
but the people of rangolap had no idea
what it was
some of the kids even stuck their
tongues out and let it fall into their
mouths
thinking it was snow despite the
enormous danger
posed to the people of rongolop the u.s
didn't evacuate them
for two days by that time the radiation
sickness
had started to take hold and
[Music]
is one of just 10 who are still alive no
one
on wronglap died that day but that
doesn't mean the bomb didn't kill them
many fell victim to thyroid cancer which
has been linked to the fallout from
bravo
and none have been able to return to
their home
i i can't go back what
i don't know
the collateral damage of nuclear testing
isn't limited only to the people of
rangala
there's another group of victims whose
pain began before a single bomb was
detonated
the 167 inhabitants of bikini atoll
to the united states once they'd
identified bikini as a suitable test
site
its people were more of an afterthought
than an obstacle
they asked him if they're they'd be
willing to move for the good of mankind
and to end all world wars
and judah the leader of the bikinians
just can't kept standing up and saying
the same answer every time he said
minute tamji
everything's in the hands of god and if
you know what i know about marshally's
culture
if someone said to me if i asked them if
i could do something they said
everything's in the hands of god
that's about as much as i know as you're
ever going to get i mean it's in the
hands of god you better be careful
um but if you watch it they did 26 takes
of this same
shot um that the commodore stands up and
dusts off his pants in the end
he says well everything being in the
hands of god it cannot be other than
good and off he walks well you tell them
and king julia that
everything being in god's hands it
cannot be
other than good with that
the people of bikini were evacuated and
while they were told of course
that they would one day be able to
return to their homes that
like so many things the marshals were
told as nuclear testing began
was a lie after they were evacuated the
bikinians underwent a grueling saga
placed by the united states here on
uninhabited wrong greek atoll which they
soon discovered had toxic fish
and land where nothing grew but i think
the u.s looked at wrong rick and looked
at bikini palm trees
sand beach looks the same you'll just go
there
and they drop them off there the bikinis
and they starve
after two years they were moved to tents
here at kwajalein base
then finally here to kili island and
meanwhile
with each bomb the americans detonated
more and more of the bikinian's land was
vaporized
the little that remained was laced with
nuclear radiation that wouldn't
dissipate
for thousands of years in late 1960s the
president johnson on the front page of
the new york times on a sunday edition
said that bikini was now safe on
recommendations from the atomic energy
commission that everybody could go back
while they were skeptical many were so
desperate to return home that they went
choosing to trust the americans perhaps
unsurprisingly
that trust was not rewarded and after
about eight or nine years
they discovered that the people were
ingesting
the food grown on the island and the
cesium
137 radioactive element was going up
into the crops and they were eating this
so it was discovered in the late 70s
that they had these very high body
burdens of
season 137 so they moved them off again
and they haven't been back since
in the end the united states dropped 67
nuclear bombs on the marshall islands
still today many parts of the country
show radiation levels that far
exceed those of chernobyl
it was really the the cold war was
fought and won by the united
states on the shores of bikini and
anyway talk in the marshall islands we
really gave a lot to the united states
and the idea that it's not even talked
about is really kind of
for lack of a better word i would say
it's insulting
as the marshall islands struggles to
lift itself from the crater of nuclear
testing
a new threat looms one whose capacity
for destruction
dwarfs that of an atomic warhead
water recall for a moment the attributes
of an atoll
comprised of coral small in size and
notably narrow
now add to that mental picture two more
tragic geological truths
atolls are extraordinarily low lying and
exceedingly flat
which is to say by their very nature
atolls are uniquely
acutely susceptible to the deadly power
of a rising sea
the implications are dire for
this at all nation and similar at all
nations
most of the atolls of the marsh islands
sit at less than six feet above
sea level marshally's homes businesses
streets people sit at less than six
feet above sea level as temperatures
rise and seize with them
that six feet begins to disappear fast
imagine an aircraft carrier
that has a free board of perhaps
i don't know 150 feet but if you
lowered that free board to six feet
and sea level rose seven feet
well the picture is pretty plain for
anyone to
to imagine and that's precisely what is
predicted to happen and what is
happening gradually
for atolls it's not just erosion but
there's actual
land loss submergence
but also the deprivation of the use
of land for any viable purpose including
simply to live on people who have not
visited an at all
have really no concept
of what it means not to have land
in an oceanic expanse as vast as
the pacific so any loss in land
is dire 30 feet of land
on a high island is
still significant but 30 feet of land
loss
or unavailability of land for living on
is a tragedy on an atoll
for the marshallese land loss isn't just
devastating from a scientific
perspective
it's corrosive to the fundamental tenets
of their culture
while nearly all societies prize land in
the marshall islands
the relationship between its people and
land is especially
precious you have to understand that
every martial ease is attached to a
piece of land
like my kids all have they know where
their pieces of land are on bikini
and that's their gift from god and
that's like their anchor in life
martial's people have a connection to
land not just the land but the ocean
right we have a connection to place
everybody owns land in the marshals
and then but just not just that every
piece of land
has some story some marking some
name you know that's ancient that's deep
what happens to that knowledge if you
lose that land
if you lose that connection what happens
to who you are
as a person to our identity but the
martialees the people who settled
distant atolls who navigated through an
unforgiving sea who endured colonization
disease war
and 63 nuclear bombs refused to allow
their ocean to be
turned into a weapon against them and so
they decided to fight back but they
couldn't do it alone
the end of the day martial islands
contributes 0.0001
of the world's global emissions we could
be the most solarized island on
the planet and it would still go
underwater if the rest of the world
doesn't take it into consideration and
make changes right
so we have to fight on a global level
what the marshallese through their
climate activism are fighting to defend
is complex
and multifaceted a combination of
culture tradition
soil coral homes language history and
people
yet what they hope to achieve can be
condensed to a single
number 1.5
1.5 degrees celsius above pre-industrial
levels
that's the magic number for the
marshallese the limit for how much the
earth can warm before their island home
becomes
uninhabitable if global temperatures
creep
above 1.5 it's lights out streets and
houses flood
land disappears crops die
above 1.5 the atolls which for thousands
of years
have supported life transform into
engines
of death mitigating climate change in
any meaningful way is already a nearly
insurmountable endeavor limiting it to
1.5
would be next to impossible the marshals
would face opposition from not only
government and industry but also from
other climate change activists whose
focus had long been
on a different number two limiting
temperature rise to two degrees above
pre-industrial levels had for many years
in the aim of policy the object of
studies and the goal of activists
in the mainstream climate change debate
two wasn't
the backup the worst case scenario the
not too bad
two was seen as the ideal the ambition
the gold
standard 1.5 on the other hand was to
many
a pipe dream it was called unrealistic
impossible
a distraction but the marshallese knew
that it was the only way for their
atolls to survive
and it was not just the marshals above
1.5
atl nations like tuvalu the maldives and
kiribati would face
the same fate among these most
vulnerable countries
a motto soon emerged 1.5
to stay alive the fight for 1.5 would be
far from easy
but they knew where it would have to be
won the 2015
united nations climate change conference
in paris where 196 countries would come
together to develop a global plan for
combating global warming
but before they could do that they had
to build
influence a martial ease government
minister named tony debroom started
building relationships and rallying
support around the world
making a name for these small marshall
islands in the big world
of climate change activism he
represented the marshals
at conferences and meetings all over the
world in copenhagen in doha
in warsaw in lima joining with other
countries as part of the alliance of
small island
states and wall debrum made impressive
progress when it comes to geopolitics
there's only so much influence and power
that can be amassed by an atoll nation
with a population lower than most small
cities so he began work on a new
coalition
one that could emerge at paris to force
the conversation to 1.5
but it needed a spark in september 2014
that spark came when the un climate
summit invited marshally's poet kathy
gentnell kishner to speak at their
opening ceremony
with the entire nation on her shoulders
she read to the gathered leaders of the
world
a letter she had written to her newborn
daughter
dear mata felipenum you are a seven
month old sunrise of gummy smiles
you are bald as an egg and bald as the
buddha
you are thighs that are thunder shrieks
that are lightning so excited for
bananas hugs and our morning walks
along the lagoon dear mata felipenum
i want to tell you about that lagoon
that lazy
lounging lagoon lounging against the
sunrise men say that one day
that lagoon will devour you they say
it will gnaw at the shoreline chew at
the roots of your bread fruit trees gulp
down rows of sea walls and crunch
through your island
shattered bones they say you
your daughter and your granddaughter too
will wander
rootless with only a passport to call
home
dear mata felipenum don't cry
no one's drowning baby no one's moving
no one's losing their homeland no one's
becoming a climate change refugee
or should i say no one else
to the carteret islanders of papua new
guinea and to the tarot islanders of
fiji i take this moment to apologize to
you
we are drawing the line here because we
baby are going to fight
your mommy daddy boo boo time your
country and your president too we will
all
fight and even though there are those
hidden behind platinum titles
who like to pretend that we don't exist
who like to pretend that the marshall
islands tuvalu kirubas maldives
typhoon haiyan in the philippines floods
of algeria colombia pakistan and all the
hurricanes earthquakes and tidal waves
didn't
exist still
there are those who see us
hands reaching out fists raising up
banners unfurling megaphones booming and
we are
canoes blocking coal ships we are the
radiance of solar villages
we are the fresh clean soil of the
farmers past
we are teenagers blooming petitions we
are
families biking recycling reusing
engineers building dreaming designing
artists
painting dancing writing and we are
spreading
the word and there are thousands out on
the streets
marching hand in hand chanting for
change
now and they're marching for you baby
they're marching for us because we
deserve to do more than just
survive we deserve to thrive
dear mata felipenum you are eyes
heavy with drowsy weight so just close
those eyes and sleep in peace
because we won't let you down you'll see
standing ovations aren't common at the
united nations
kathy's lasted a full minute
why do you think poetry is
an effective means of activism what is
it about poetry that you think
makes people listen um why to make them
well i think poetry forces people to
slow down and connect to the emotion of
the issue right
rather than just facts and data and
fear and you know um uh
written statements right poetry is
personal poetry connects you to the
issue
and connects you to why you should care
about the issue and then
it was time to go to paris the paris
conference lasted 14 days
and for the first 11 nearly all
discussion centered around
two degrees but in the final three days
of negotiation
tony de brume began to execute his plan
when he unveiled
the high ambition coalition a previously
secret alliance of over 90 countries
that tony had spent
the last year coalescing the high
ambition coalition
ranged from the small atoll of kiribati
to the powerful nations of the european
union
and together they turned the entire
conference on its head
demanding the agreement include 1.5
it was such a jarring and extraordinary
show of power orchestrated by such a
small nation
that many said it couldn't be real
chinese negotiators called it
meaningless representatives from
bangladesh called it a stunt
and in truth it was not completely clear
just how formal this coalition was
when pressed tony couldn't even say how
many members it had
but it didn't matter because the
momentum had already changed
new countries began to join argentina
brazil
chile iceland sweden before long a
majority of the represented nations
supported 1.5
in less than three days tony de brume
took 1.5
from pipe dream to reality in the end
184 countries resolved that they would
quote
hold the increase in the global
temperature to well below 2 degrees
celsius above pre-industrial levels
and pursue efforts to limit the
temperature increase to 1.5 degrees
celsius
above pre-industrial levels they got 1.5
in there
right 1.5 huge for us the global
temperature
you know to maintain our our survival
that before we went to that conference i
was told by many people that 1.5
wouldn't make it in there
it would it was too hard you know even
though for our survival we need that
temperature to be recognized
yeah tony was the one that orchestrated
that
and so beyond that you know we've also
uh we've also continued that momentum
from tony's legacy once he passed on
yes we were kind of a a champion
for climate change in the paris meeting
you know by working with a group of
people
which were what's called the eye
ambition group and
it was kind of amazing for us to be able
to
gather a number of people who supported
us
during the meetings and resulted in the
paris it was an enormous
unexpected deserved victory but it
didn't
last the paris agreement was without a
doubt
the most important collective step the
world had made towards solving climate
change
it was also in many ways a complete and
utter
failure many of the pledges made by
countries were unspecific
unambitious and perhaps most importantly
unenforceable
in paris the world promised to pursue
efforts to limit temperatures to 1.5
already in 2015 it was a weak promise
the five years since have proved it
meaningless
paris was supposed to serve as a
starting place with more ambitious
pledges to be made in the future
now it is the future and the more
ambitious pledges
are nowhere to be found and even the
inadequate commitments of paris have
often been completely
ignored in stories the underdog
is supposed to win when they give it
their all when they combine dreams and
drive
when they form a high ambition coalition
when they read dear mata felipenum
when they chant 1.5 to stay alive it's
supposed to work
today projections show that under the
best case scenario
will reach 1.5 in 2052
worst case 2030. either way
in a few short decades three millennia
of
marshally civilization will come to an
end
already today flooding and inundation
are common
in the marshall islands but things get
especially bad during what the
marshalles call
king tides the islands are becoming
more and more inundated with waters
during spring night and also during
kingstein well when the high
high type king tight comes it destroys
the whole village
the water coming to the comes to the
road my cousin lost her house in a
really bad king tide flooding
since 2011 we've seen more and more king
tides
a combination of lunar cycles wind
patterns
and of course rising seas coalesce into
waves that flood streets
yards and homes for the marshallese the
destruction and disorder king tides
bring
have become an increasingly normal part
of everyday life
we're flat as a pancake here and and if
you go out today at 5 5
45's the high tide you know why i know
that because yesterday i was driving
home a little after five and the water
was fly i drive volkswagens the water
splashing on a
salt water splashing on a volkswagen is
not a good feeling because they they
melt with the rust
and so i knew today i always know when
the high tide is because i worry about
that kind of stuff but other people
worry about it too because it's hitting
their houses
you never used to know when high tides
were out unless you were someone who's
out at the sea all the time and you're a
diver or whatever
and you counted on that stuff but now
everybody kind of knows when the big
high tide's going to be and they know
what they have to do we never used to
think like that here ever
flooding and inundation don't just
destroy what's been created
on the atoll it also destroys the
atoll's ability to create
the water is coming up on the crown too
and also contaminating our
well waters and affecting our
food crops and of course the breadfruit
trees that we used to
depend on to build our canoes and
provide foods
are dying because the the water lengths
and the
on this island getting smaller and small
and
you know they cannot survive the salt
water
but the most pressing effect of climate
change is also perhaps the most
unexpected
so currently the most uh urgent effects
are illnesses so climate-related
illnesses like
dengue mosquito-borne illnesses are
supposed to increase with
you know climate effects so we've had we
have three different health issues we're
dealing with right now on the marshall
islands the first of course is dengue
fever that's been going on for about
eight months now we've been in a state
of health emergency
um the second one is uh and we've had
over 25 cases
uh 2500 cases of the
of dengue since uh last july
and so that's been our major battle
we're fighting right here now and then
secondly we've had measles which we
haven't had a case yet before we've put
in all kinds of preventative measures
and of course coronavirus in the same
category we're just trying to prevent it
we haven't had any yet
but we're being very strict with how
people come in actually
the way i feel is that most of what
we're seeing right now is climate change
a result of climate change with rising
temperatures come more mosquitoes
increasing the risk of transmission for
insect-borne diseases like zika
and dengue more severe water cycles
flooding high rainfalls
drought all propagate contaminated water
supplies increasing the spread of
cholera
e coli and other diarrheal diseases in
fact
for almost every infectious disease out
there malaria
ebola lyme west nile typhoid research
predicts that climate change
will make it worse according to the
world health organization
over the next 20 years over 2 million
people
will die as a result of climate change
related
disease this is like not normal this is
not nothing that we've ever experienced
before
we're in the eighth month of a state of
health emergency the marshall islands
has never been in a state of health
emergency this long ever
we've never seen a bigger disease
outbreak we've never seen all these
deaths throughout the pacific in recent
times from things like measles that we
thought were gone
so i think the really important thing
that people have to understand is
this is not the way things used to be
but this is the way it's becoming now
normal and that to me is
as a result of the massive climate
change and the massive warming that's
been going on
you have to start talking about health
when you and connecting it to climate
change
because there's no other explanation for
this there really isn't
when you combine it all inundation land
loss
crop death coral bleaching drought
disease
a single clear picture forms
these are all becoming a potent package
which are linked
to the adverse effects of climate change
and that potency
is a bit too much or beyond the
capability
of small at all nations to respond to
and so
all of these packaged potent
adverse effects are proving to be
catastrophic
the future that the marshall highlands
fought so hard to prevent
is already coming to pass the islands
are dying
and soon they'll be truly permanently
and irreversibly uninhabitable
two options have emerged stay
and fight a losing battle or leave and
start a new life
in truth though those options are the
same the only variable
is time thousands of miles away
far from the fury of the ocean a new
atoll
is emerging one encircled not by sea but
by streets
a land made not of coral but of concrete
one where abundance is measured
not by the size of your family but
rather the sum of your money
one dotted not by palm trees but by
poultry plants
hope is not plentiful for the
marshallese but there's a spark of it
here
nestled in the northwestern corner of
arkansas
springdale is i would describe it as
more of a blue-collar
working-class community in the midst of
a
thriving area of northwest arkansas one
of the top five
fastest growing areas in the country and
we are a very diverse city we've got 44
languages spoken in our school district
our our two largest minorities would be
uh
latino which is probably somewhere
around 35 to 40 percent
could be a little higher we'll find out
in the 2020 census
uh and uh and a large martial east
population
uh we've been told the largest martial
east population outside the
united states or outside of the marshall
islands exact figures
vary 2010 census numbers peg it in the
low thousands
but that figure is almost certainly
inaccurate
in reality currently it is believed that
as many
as 15 000 marshalees live in the
springdale area
one-fifth of all marshally's people
tucked away
in this small ozark city of course
in a country of countless options the
question to some might be
why springdale arkansas the story as
it's told
begins in 1979. a marshallese man
named john moody was awarded a
scholarship to the university of
oklahoma
a dream coming from a nation yet to have
a single college
moody soon decided though that he wasn't
cut out for the academic life
he shifted paths taking a job at a
poultry plant in muskogee oklahoma
earning 3.25 an hour
multiples more than any comparable job
in the marshalls
soon though the business took him to the
largest poultry producer
in the world tyson foods headquartered
in springdale
arkansas pay was decent openings were
plentiful
and english was optional so ward soon
traveled from moody to his family in the
marshalls that
springdale was the land of opportunity
so they came
and spread the word to others and they
came and spread the word
and more came and spread the word and
soon enough as the social networks of a
small nation
saturated with the promise of a better
life springdale established itself
as the destination for marshally's
immigration to the u.s
now decades on what started as one man
in a chicken plant has turned into
the largest population of marshallese
outside of the islands
themselves the city has 30 odd marshalls
churches
has become a key campaign stop for
marshall's politicians
and it's even home to a tiny consulate
representing the marshallese government
itself
the mission is one of just eight the
marshals have abroad
sharing a modest two-story building with
a barber accountant and lawyer
it is the only consulate of any nation
for hundreds of miles
and one of only two in the state of
arkansas
it's staffed just by an assistant the
consul's wife
and the consul general himself my name
is eldon alek
i'm the consulate general for the rebel
of the marshall islands
here in springdale arkansas the job of
the consulate is to uh
number one provide consular services to
the martial citizens here
and uh uh assist the marshalls
population here uh
with whatever they need try to be the uh
the eyes and ears of the government of
the marshall islands here
call its luck or call its intuition but
moody and the thousands that followed
were right to choose springdale
as their new homes the city has been
experiencing a
decades-long economic boom we have an
entrepreneurial
uh spirit here in in northwest arkansas
not only springdale
but we've seen uh many fortune 100
companies
uh uh walmart of course about 30 miles
north
we've got tyson right here in springdale
which is
the first or second largest protein
producer in the world we have a because
of our growth
certainly the building industry they're
building trades
there's a lot going on here that you
know our unemployment
uh right now is is just barely over two
percent
in springdale pretty much anyone who
wants one no matter their age origin or
education level
can get a job in springdale well
marshallese we we generally like to
follow one another we come here to be
near our families
the poultry industry doesn't really take
a lot of skills and education people
just come here and they can work
they're going to arrive today and work
tomorrow under the compact of free
association
any marshally citizen can live and work
in the u.s
a right others at best wait years
or decades to attain but there are still
barriers
perhaps the most significant is the
first getting there
a one-way plane ticket from measure to
springdale costs about
1500 a substantial sum for anyone
but a fortune in the marshall islands
there
fifteen hundred dollars is half a year's
wage
in springdale though fifteen hundred is
less than a month
some families they come here little by
little
sometimes they just send the the father
first
and then the mother and then the kids
and then the parents the grandparents
so they just do a little by little each
earns enough to pay for the next
over time bringing the entire family to
springdale
so we did a study and
a majority of the people that actually
took this study
replied that family responsibility was
the first
reason why they moved you know and
usually their departure from the islands
are very very
unplanned that's because you know a
sister would call in and say hey
i have some money i have some money to
buy your ticket get ready
uh you're gonna be on the plane in the
next two weeks so you can come and help
me with
with my mom or you know with someone so
i can find a job and
while you take care of the the family
member you know i have a way to
to bring income into the house despite
their political
economic and social connections though
the marshall islands and the united
states
are not the same and the adjustment is
not always
easy there's so many cultural barriers
that that
are that we see on a daily basis
one is marsley's culture is a very
sharing culture
you know one property is owned by
everyone it's just not an
individual uh ownership of their
property but
you know everyone in that clan owns it
and and when you look in terms of
households
um it is perfectly okay for
for multiple family members to live
under one roof
uh whereas you know here you know you
have those
um they enforce code where it's
prohibited
you know i don't know what the codes of
ordinances in the marshall islands
look like but i can i can be pretty
confident they're quite a bit different
than ours
here in springdale arkansas we came from
we came from a world that
money really didn't mean anything for us
but here it is uh people in the united
states
they're economically driven was we're
not
we never had to pay rent we never have
to worry about
um having a lot of money so we can
buy food because you know you have our
biggest
refrigerator was the ocean and it was
right there
it's readily available so we really
didn't have to worry about
saving you're comparing a very small
world to a big world
nonetheless in making the difficult
transition to america
having a familiar community makes it
easier
you're surrounded by over 35 churches
that's amazing and you have a consul
general's office here
you have our office as well you have
other non-profit uh
offices as well and the the people are
very supportive in this area are very
supportive of the marshley's
community it kind of like uh give you
that value
in in preserving your culture and and i
think
and i think that's why i refer uh
springdale to as
uh springdale atolls because this is
really the culture
this is the the hub of uh the culture
popular media might predict that the
story of a group of people
from a far-off land descending on and
settling a small southern city would end
in tension and animosity that
is not the story of springdale you know
i wish i knew what the secret sauce was
for that because i think we could use
that
in a lot of places throughout our
country uh this openness and willingness
to
to accept change and and i don't want to
candy coat it uh
you know there are other people who grew
up here just like me
that continued to talk about the good
old days and the days
you know when we grew up and things were
different
but you know i'm just reminded that
we're somebody's good old days right now
the people growing up here right now
look back we'll look back on this time
as the good old days no matter what it
looks like
and uh and so i think i think a
willingness
on the part of the people of springdale
to uh
to treat people as human beings surely
surely there's nothing special about
springdale
surely everyone every place can do that
springdale as it exists for the
marshallese is fortuitous
fortuitous because john moody and the
early migrants who followed had no
idea of their island's bleak fate they
migrated for a brighter economic future
but now with the direct threat of a
rising ocean
marshallese are starting to migrate to
escape the water
i think some some people have moved
because of sea level rise
and that wasn't the case maybe maybe
five ten years ago
people were coming here for better
opportunities but
i've talked to some people and they've
come here for sea level race
plan is staying and live there and and
fight
uh fight the climate change but if plan
plan a doesn't work
you know this is where i feel the
calling
this is where i need to be at but if
really if that happens
that's wow that that's taking away
our identity you know that's that's
basically stripping us
down to the bare skin and i'm not sure
how i'm going to take that that will be
very hard for me to
to process however i feel
that i can't just cry and feel
sad because that happened i have to do
something
i have to make reestablished i feel like
reestablishing
somewhere else that is safe
that provides you the freedom the
freedom to make a choice
uh is is probably my next thing that i
will focus on
plan a is still very much in motion for
many
most martialees are still at their home
fighting to hold on to their lives
as long as the waters will allow them
those who can
buy a few additional years by building a
wall between them
and the ocean well we call this we call
this a concrete wall
so we first we build the concrete base
about five to six feet wide and two feet
from the from the ground when the high
tide come
not even normal like other ones are the
dive wound
and after i build wall there
and people there they're living happy
there i see
i see that the sea wall has been
protecting them
but there's other people same village
the other people live on the other side
about two
two house from the outside of the sea
wall
now they're affecting because there's no
wall there
if wall wasn't here there's the wall
here
i know that the water the trash the
rocks they were
coming right here they're going
one two how many houses there yeah and
it's been happening forever it's been
happening over and over
every kick tight's coming they're always
like that
they're bringing rocks and trash
do you think sea walls could protect
majoro for 200 years 300 years
oh no don't trust me believe me
even though we're making wall it's not
going to protect because we're
we're damaging the reef and if as long
as you drill the reef
and building concrete wall
you're messing with the mother nature
you know at this point
the goal is not to prevent the
destruction of the marshals
just to delay it if the time limit
is in five years then
you know it's we moved five years but
between now and five years
we want to make sure that we spend
every minute thinking about how to
survive on these islands just like our
ancestor did
land is supposed to be the embodiment of
permanence
a nation is nothing without its land but
now
the marshall islands is temporary in the
back of everyone's mind
is the realization that the soil they
stand on will eventually be
submerged you know with our
infrastructure projects
you know what are we doing why are we
doing this you know 20 30 40 years
it could be swamped underwater
i don't know it's like you know part of
the work you do is try to prepare for
the
you know the the future of
submerging and part of it is you just
carry on
with your day-to-day activities which
means you know look these projects are
still
funded they're on the books they're
approved we still got to do them
now when is that going to change i
don't know i don't know it's going to
take some kind of
visible tipping point somewhere then i
think for that to happen
i mean really i mean significant
not just a high king tide you know we've
had those
or another el nino again we've had those
i think it's going to take something
else maybe
unfortunately it may be worse for us to
i don't know then get to the realization
well this is it
you know we've got to stop
and just to avenue of activity and
divert the energies
into some other kind of future well
when you think when people say to me
that you they
think the marshall islands has a time
limit
i think they have to start thinking
about the bigger picture here
we're the canary in the coal mine if we
have a limited
time here then so does everywhere else i
mean this is the way this is the way
it's evolving
and so many times we've been the canary
out there we were the canary in the coal
mine
for nuclear testing um now we're the
canary in the coal mine for climate
change
the reason why this our ocean is mad
and is it crawling closer to our
living room it's because the same people
that brought in
the nuclear testing to the country are
the same people that are doing this
they're trying to find resource first
they try to find the power to control
the world
and using our islands to test the
nuclear weapon
then they went back and tried to find
the best way to gain resources in a
short period of time
by using things that would destroy
the world and mother nature is not happy
so she's coming back to us
but in a very roaring way we as
marshall's people enter the conversation
of climate change
as survivors of the nuclear legacy as in
we already understand what it means to
have lost homes to have lost that
connection to land
to have something ripped ripped away
from us for globe because of global
needs and you know because of a global
concern or whatever right the u.s
decided to test nuclear weapons in the
marshall islands because
we were seen as disposable and now with
climate change happening more and less
and less people care about it you know
there are
very few people who care about it and
the ones in power don't care about it
because again
we're seen as disposable that's the
intersection between climate change and
the nuclear legacy
we've experienced it already and that's
why we're fighting even harder against
climate change we don't want to lose the
rest of our islands we've already
experienced
that loss and that trauma we we are
going to be
the first climate change refugees i
truly believe that
that's happening and people are in
denial
of it because they're responsible for it
this is my country
this is where i live this is where my
kids go to school this is where i
i want them to all be and this is the
society i want them to contribute to
i think it's you know it's a
tough concept to think about it's like
thinking
if you have children thinking about them
being in a car accident or getting
a terminal illness you don't want to
think about it because it's so painful
[Music]
you know we love our culture we love our
custom and
we love the way of life that we have
here if we were to
leave go somewhere else we would
probably lose our customers probably
lose our ability to
look after ourselves and as a people
right now it's still a debate
in many of these first world nations
what do we do can we do it
what are the changes we can make do we
believe in it is it even real
is it worth the funding can we change
that's not where we're at where we're at
is very much
it's going to happen we have to figure
out how to plan for it
we probably will be looking back at our
country from
a higher ground this is going to be
wow this is this is going to be
something
you know that i just can't describe in
terms of you know culturally
as a people civilization what this is
going to mean
for the kids and grandkids
to be honest i'm worried about my
generation and the next generation
and the future on because when we
migrate the main the main thing i'm
scared of is
our culture you know if everyone leaves
here where will our culture go
and our culture will slowly fade away no
one knows about our culture
our people and especially marshall
islands
yeah it hits me every time but like i i
really try to ignore
it but it i can't because
it's always trending it's always getting
talked about and
we really can't put it aside because
we're really affected now
and if we can't do anything now the
future
will be affected if we don't do anything
now
personally me i really don't want to go
to other countries i really want to stay
here and
live the best life in the islands and
really share
the like full of joy and
you know here right here in the marshall
islands this island really means a lot
and just imagine if different countries
if we told them that their country
doesn't matter and they can just move
here
and they would feel the same way that it
it feels special for us to have this
place because it's unique
and our culture really lies here
[Music]
people can move a nation cannot
and though they'll try any transposition
loses
fidelity with each generation the
picture's
fuzzy the memories fade
the marshall islands has endured for
millennia
but it was never immortal nations have
ended before
nations will end again of all the ends
the marshall islands could meet though
this one stings most to be killed by the
ocean
its creator turned against it
by people who don't even know its name
[Music]
so
you
[Music]
um
you